how did you guys exactly meet the first  day you ever met the truth  is so powerful because it doesn't change  yes the truth was cheech was  up in canada dodging the draft getting  out of the draft the  serendipity thing was that he moved  right  where i was raised right to the same  neighborhood  we get to the border and the canadian  immigration are wearing flak jackets  why because these famous  stoners are invading their country  are you kidding no stop getting searched  we had  all that [ __ ] and we would get caught i  would get caught  you still bring the weed i'm not just  here  to be here yes i'm here to spread  the gospel you know you know to get weed  legal to be part of it